the jogan experience I watch a whole
bunch of [__] it's called like one is
nature is
metal that's a sick page bro nature is
metal it's the craziest [__] the
craziest nature is so metal it is dude
some of the [__] you see on that page is
nuts but you'll see a bear and it'll
just walk around and it just [__]
everybody up but then when there's a
bear that's as big as it it starts to
question and it might cower down but in
this situation Mike Tyson's not going to
cower down the Lewis so he bites
him right he bites him he he probably
fell down I'm going tell you one thing I
tell you this right now when I was in
that press fight with Jon Jones I was
still undefeated at the time and we were
at the MGM Grand and he headbutted me
like put his head on me so I push him
he's an alpha male too so the [__]
attacks me right right so we get to
fight
it oh boy so we get to fighting right
and we're fighting and Joe the security
guard from the UFC falls under me but
now I'm on my back as we go flying off
the
stage I will say that was a thought to
bite the [__] like what am I
doing on my
back right I'm losing bite this son of a
[__] I ain't got no mouthpiece in my
mouth like and if I would have bit him
that would have been like a reaction for
a guy that usually will walk around in
most places around this world as the
alpha and then when he finds himself on
the bottom as the alpha he's got to find
a way to survive so that's what Mike
Tyson would do he would go as Primal as
he could think how do I survive it was
always survival with this guy
wow wow and if I would have bit him
you'd have been like DC bit him but it's
not the first time we saw somebody bite
a [__] down there cuz Mike Tyson
did it three times you can't make no
mistake against he's a tough yeah he's
tough he's so tough yeah he's very tough
I was very upset when the Jones tpe
fight got cancelled I was
like we were looking forward to it have
you ever had an injury like that where
it's torn off the bone no it was a very
odd injury for me to watch to because it
didn't seem like it was like like you
know grappling wrestling we get extended
a lot right like so when you're going
and you're doing youu Jiu-Jitsu and you
and I are going and you take and I'm
you're in half guard right every time I
go to get up I build to my elbow I get
to my underhook I'll take a single leg
you'll sprawl because you got to take
your leg away from me when I'm up on my
elbow and I get to my half guard and I'm
on the butt here I will always go to
single because because I'm a wrestler
you will sprawl and then try to go back
behind me my arm gets extended every
time and that's kind of what happened
with Jones it's like he was in and
underhook and the guy sprawled a little
bit and then his arm came away away from
his body and it ripped and it's it's
unfortunate but do you think that um I
know John has been doing a lot of heavy
lifting y to get up to heavy weight that
and the extra weight right he's carrying
all that extra weight he's lifting all
that weight and it's like you got to
develop muscle but it's got to be usable
muscle you can't just be big well the
other thing is if if you're not doing
anything like if you're not taking
anything then your recovery from like
really heavy power lifts is kind of
significant didn't he lift like 600 lb
or something oh my God he's strong as
[__] he's strong as [__] he looks very
big now like he looks like a heavyweight
but I just wonder how much weightlifting
do you have to do to maintain that frame
yeah you know well he was strong he was
when we fought he was strong like he was
strong leverage great with his leverage
dude the the way he was able to
manipulate positions because I thought
without a shadow of a doubt that I would
take him down at will but it's hard even
if you get a takedown it's hard against
the best guys I picked Stipe up I threw
him down held him down for the whole
first round and
then he got up because we got to start
again so now I got to start that process
all over again and that's why Habib n
Med off was so special because it didn't
matter how many times he had to restart
the process he went right back to doing
that with his opponent knowing that he
was going to throw you to the ground so
when you're fighting guys like Jones
he's so tall he's so rangy and he just
understood fighting the guy just
understands fighting and it makes him
hard to deal with and then
Joe when you get in a clinch with this
dude he's so tall that it's almost like
you're holding him up if you're the
shorter fighter he's like draping over
the top of you and that is what fatigues
you because when I'm clinching you know
I fought there a ton like just in the
clinch punch punch punch I'm trying to
break your posture he doesn't do that he
pushes you against the octagon and then
he leans so now you're carrying 220 with
your weight up against the octagon and
it's like and then he's changing level
and he's spinning trying to Elbow you
the dude just understands fighting and
understands how to maneuver his body to
fatigue you it's crazy he also is the
best at managing distance oh gosh it
hurts so bad trying to get close to him
I tell you that hey dude it hurts so bad
Jo it hurts so bad
the kicks to the body and the knees cuz
you know me like Kane me and Kane were
forward forward forward head movement
get close punch those punch take you
down right but with him he was a South
ball so his lead leg was right there so
I wanted to grab a single leg but this
dude would be stepping back kneeing me
kneeing me kneeing me and then I'll be
like okay so I need to stop going
forward so now I'm at range and he
blasts body kick and then body kick so
now you're like [__] I'm not going to
stay on the end of these body kicks cuz
they hurt so then you get get close and
he needs you so it's like you're landing
and I'm hitting him but he's hitting me
with things that may not be as big like
my hand overhand right looks big but
that knee just goes boom right in the
rib every time boom right in the rib and
then every now and again they catch you
right in the
middle that [__] hurts bad man I don't
even know how the hell I was going
through all that in that octagon because
now it hurts it hurts like it hurts Alex
Pereira kicked my leg I was like this
[__]
hurts